il avait accusé ni plus ni moins d'avoir
commandité l'assassinât du journaliste
jamal radiologie redjep tayyip erdogan
fait un virage à 180° en accueillant
aujourd'hui le prince d'arabie saoudite
mohamed ben salman à ankara pour serrer
la réconciliation avec son grand rival
au sein de l'islam sunnite kalidou sy
nous en dit plus
dans un instant
le sujet tout de suite une embrassade
pour des retrouvailles sous le signe de
la réconciliation
mohammed bin salman revenu en turquie
pour la première fois depuis 2018 et
l'assassinât de l'opposant et
journaliste saoudien jamal rachid j une
visite attendue par le président turc
recep tayyip erdogan les deux hommes
s'étaient déjà rencontrés en avril
dernier en arabie saoudite
un échange au moment où la turquie
cherche des partenaires pour faire face
à une grave crise économique et
l'inflation galopante déjà avant cette
première visite la justice turque sur
demande du pouvoir avait transféré la
paire a choisi aux autorités de ryad
jamal racho dix journalistes saoudiens
opposants à mohammed bin salman tombe en
octobre 2018 dans un guet-apens au
consulat saoudien istanbul il est
séquestré torturé puis assassiné par un
commando de forces spéciales soupçonnée
d'avoir agi avec l'aval du prince
héritier la tournée régionale de ben
salman intervient par ailleurs trois
semaines avant une visite de joe biden
en arabie saoudite mais le président
américain s'est déjà défendu de vouloir
rencontrer en tête-à-tête le prince
héritier je n'y vais pas pour le
rencontrer je ne vais pas rencontré
mohammed bin salman je vais à une
réunion internationale et il se trouve
qu'il y sera comme d'autres parties
prenantes aux discussions dans la région
aujourd'hui
après une phase d'isolement suite à
l'assassinât du journaliste saoudien le
prince héritier reçoit petit à petit
l'absolution des différents chefs d'état
du monde entier en décembre 2021 c'est
le président français emmanuel macron
qu'il avait personnellement rencontré en
arabie saoudite
et on va plus loin avec marie roger
biloa directrice du groupe africa
international et qui nous suit depuis le
cameroun aujourd'hui bonjour marie roger
dont je rappelle efface avoue bruno
daroux de la rédaction de france 24 dont
jambonneau bonjour à feu alors il faut
dire après ce qu'on vient de voir un que
fin avril c'était lui le président turc
recep tayyip erdogan qui avait fait le
premier pas en se rendant en arabie
saoudite cette fois ça y est le
réchauffement est actée bono oui d'une
certaine manière le réchauffement est
actée ou la réelle politique est de
retour ou nécessité fait loi comme vous
et en tout cas effectivement il semble
bien que la très grande brouille les
graves accusations portées par le
président regard de haine contre les
autorités saoudiennes après
l'assassinât dans des conditions
parfaitement scabreuse du journaliste
jamal khashoggi et ben semble bien que
tout ça soit passer par pertes et
profits parce que évidemment la
situation et que la turquie est dans une
situation économique difficile que non
que le président gardois n'a besoin
d'attirer des investissements pour faire
tourner son économie où l'inflation
chiffre officiel est à 70% mais on
estime ça pour être autour de 140 150 %
vous voyez ici on a 5 % commencent à
s'inquiéter voyez là-bas c'est quand
même une situation très difficile il en
plus des élections dans un nom dont il
faut qu'il fasse quelque chose qu'il
trouve de l'argent ou est-ce qu'à
l'argent notamment dans les pétro
monarchies adieu les principes ce
rapprochement il change quoi
concrètement sur la sur la scène
politique internationale mari roger
sauva que c'est pas tellement ce qui les
intéresse lieu en ce moment en
particulier
recep tayyip erdogan
c'est le jeu toujours de timber résister
le plus longtemps à l'appel de la pluie
de milliards de dollars les sentiers et
donc on a signalé déjà ce dire on a vu
cette histoire de gammal cassure gris
qui a qui a choqué le monde entier pas
seulement du mali et qui est on se
disait à l'époque les ce sera l'occasion
quand même deux de marquer le coup face
à l'arabie saoudite qui se croient tout
permis parce que je crois qu'il ya
toutes sortes de contentieux et à
l'histoire de la guerre du lait même il
ya le fait que l'arabie saoudite cac a
beaucoup fait danser le djihadisme en
afrique et qu'ils ont attiré plus de
conséquences de rien mais là un citoyen
américain en mondovision
il y aura des conséquences mans ça
commençait déjà par le fait que monsieur
le président de l'époque donald trump a
refusé tout de suite de condamner dit
tout ça voilà je ne crois même pas les
services secrets américains disent
qu'elles ont de preuves de son
implication
mais avec byden on s'y dit voilà on va
tenir c'est bon c'est pas on connaît la
realpolitik et on sait que les droits
humains une personnalité qui tu es comme
ça même si ses partisans comme est
sacrifié sur l'autel des intérêts plus
tard ça c'est pas une beauté s'installer
aux autres musées mais dans ce cas
précis c'était juste une question de
combien de temps vont obtenir et donc
il ya trois économies au bord de la
faillite pour l'egypte n'a pas contesté
beaucoup de cette histoire là ni la
jordanie les deux pays où il s'est rendu
avant mais c'était surtout la turquie la
turquie est allé très loin dans la
dénonciation c'est elle et elle a publié
des enregistrements
de l'ambassade de l'assassinât de cassio
guise était absolument horrible tout ce
taux est de 5,6 et ils sont très loin et
on rit non que les procès il ya une
liste de gens qui voulaient qu'ils sont
ont été condamnés par contumace
et on voit tout ça s'effondre assez
rapidement déjà en avril il n'a pas
raison il y la palabre il il a été déjà
la barre mais il a il a transféré
toulouse y est judiciaire en arabie
saoudite ce qui était maintenant
clairement de première catégorie dans ce
que ça va changer eh bien je crois que
les alliances habituels vont persister
on à la russie la turquie qui joue son
jeu habituel entre eux la même si une
europe qui veut jouer des rôles
importants qui veut exister s'affirmer
comme une puissance moyenne dans cette
région très complexe et là ce qui compte
le plus pour le moment c'est de
renflouer ses caisses c'est et voilà on
reste
assez secondaire il faut dire un beau
bruno que j'étais hyper douanes
aujourd'hui se cherche des alliés dans
une situation économique
particulièrement difficile quand même
pour la turquie oui on l'a on l'a déjà
dit on à la turquie je citais les
chiffres depuis je ne sais pas si tu es
là la monnaie turquie s'est
littéralement effondré les chiffres de
l'inflation
les est cité et encore une fois il ya
des élections qui sont prévues dans un
an donc respecté hyper douane il sait
très bien que sa population a de plus en
plus de mal à vivre en entendez les
débats tout à l'heure sur les
difficultés de pouvoir d'achat en france
pour faire en turquie cette fois trois
fois quatre fois cinq ans plus de 70 %
d'inflation voilà c'est le chiffre
officiel est jeune et le chiffre réel
est estimée par certains économistes à
140 150 % non c'est absolument
considérable il en plus le poids aussi
des des réfugiés la turquie accueille
près de quatre millions de réfugiés
syriens et évidemment l'objectif de
rochester perdon c'est d'être réélu l'an
prochain il fera tout pour voilà on
verra quels moyens il emploie pour nous
pour être réélu mais il a un message
envoyé à son opinion il le fait
d'ailleurs par ce biais là en recevant
mohammed bin salman est donc en espérant
avoir des investissements assez
important dé de l'arabie saoudite mais
plus globalement des pétromonarchies
dans son économie pour mettre un peu
d'huile dans tout ça il ne fait aussi
sur un point de vue plus symboliques
plus nationalistes en recréant ça c'est
un autre phénomène depuis quelques jours
de la tension avec la grèce sur la
question de la méditerranée orientale et
la du statut des îles de la mer egée
notamment les îles du dodécanèse qui
sont tout proche de la turquie ou en
gros ils accusent la grèce de ne pas
respecter le traité international de
1923 selon lequel il ne devait pas y
avoir d'armes grec sur ces fameuses îles
du dodécanèse donc sa recrue nathan sûr
mais il le fait pour des raisons de
politique intérieure pour faire
diversion par rapport à la situation
économique et que les gens se disent ah
on a un leader fort qui voilà qui tient
la dragée haute aux grecs donc vous
voyez que ratchet tayyip erdogan il est
dans cette situation qu'il sait
difficile et il essaye dans un coup un
coup de diplomatie avec la grèce de
tensions diplomatiques un coup
d'économies avec les pétromonarchies il
essaye de s'en sortir au mieux et en
face mari roger bernat à un prince
saoudien qui a après avoir vu son
ascension à 2-2 au grand réformateur
stoppée net par cette affaire a shoji
entrevoit la possibilité d'un retour sur
le devant de la scène avec la vie un job
island où l'avait mentionné le mois
prochain
oui certainement je crois que la
normalisation est quasi totale comme
l'avait déjà bruno est du côté de ceux
qui le combattaient qui pensaient
pouvoir tenir tête à retenir texte aux
milliards de dollars vous dire que
aujourd'hui il a près d'un milliard de
dollars par vous dans les caisses qui
tombent dans les caisses de du roi nommé
dame et saint dié ces derniers mois
grâce commandes brutes et donc ils avoir
limité on voit finances est pratiquement
illimité est en place ils mangent leur
chapeau et déboucherait monsieur banane
particulier maintenant qu'est ce qu'on
fait on est dans le scénic et donc on se
rabat sur le symbolique le panda et
molaires ou que ça tout à l'heure mais
habits de la turquie et de la grèce mais
là aux états unis qu'est ce qu'on a ça a
beaucoup choqué puisque jamais à celui
était journaliste à elle travaillé pour
lui à son poste dans la ville de
washington on a créé une rue jamal
cassou dit juste en face de l'ambassade
d'arabie saoudite
ce qu'on l'avait déjà fait pour boris
nemtsov
opposant russe qui avait été tué en 2015
près de qom là il ya aussi l'adresse de
l'ambassade de russie à washington c'est
plaza et boris même sur place voilà mais
la chine elle a réussi à bloquer le
projet d'hommage ingouche yambo kyi et
les dirigeants chinois qui ont créé le
prix nobel en 2010 et gay mort en
détention mais et on a essayé mais ça ça
arrive tout donc on est dans le
symbolique et il y en a qui sont
puissants que d'autres même pour
empêcher bruno daroux juge de choses
comme cette visite de joe biden quand
même elle va pas être simple parce que
joe biden avait dit pis que pendre de
mourad ben salman et il avait dit six
jours en arabie saoudite je rencontre le
monarque le père donc de mohammad bin
salman pas question de rencontrer ce
type en quelque sorte c'était je traduis
sa pensée à quel point au près bon on va
voir dans trois semaines
s'il pourra éviter rencontre et moins
jeunes salman certainement pas il va
peut-être évité de faire de la publicité
à ces rencontres mais c'est tout ce
qu'il pourra faire car ceux qui jouent
pour moi ben salman et les
pétromonarchies c'est la guerre en
ukraine merci vladimir poutine grâce à
cette guerre est bien les
pétromonarchies il se retrouve en
position de force parce que évidemment
les pays occidentaux ont besoin du
pétrole et d'un pétrole pas trop cher
que les saoudiens des pétromonarchies
libère un peu de leur stock ils se sont
d'ailleurs plus ou moins engagés là
dessus pour les mois de juillet et août
d'ores et déjà donc ça les met en
position de force autre sujet il a été
réélu voilà deux mois alors qu'il
contrôlait le parlement ici en france
une situation inédite sous la vème
république mme emmanuelle matrouh macron
va-t-il pouvoir gouverner la france rien
n'est moins sûr le président n'a pas
loin s'en faut la majorité absolue à
l'assemblée à l'issue des élections
législatives qui avaient lieu dimanche
après avoir deux jours durant consulter
les dirigeants des formations
nouvellement élu à l'assemblée il vient
de prendre la parole ce soir à la
télévision en voici un extrait la
plupart des dirigeants que j'ai reçus
ont exclu l'hypothèse d'un gouvernement
d'union nationale
laquelle d'ailleurs n'est à mes yeux pas
justifié ce jour
beaucoup ont aussi fait part de leur
disponibilité pour avancer sur des
sujets majeurs est urgent pour votre
quotidien le pouvoir d'achat le travail
les moyens d'atteindre le plein emploi
la transition écologique la sécurité je
crois qu'il est donc possible dans le
moment crucial que nous vivons de
trouver une majorité plus large et plus
claire pour agir
pas d'union nationale 1 bruno daroux
néanmoins emmanuel macron ch semble
évoquer une majorité plus large est ce
que ça va pas surtout se terminer par
des majorités de projets mais pas de
coalition majorité alors le mouillé il a
évoqué un
une possibilité d'une coalition enfin
franchement je pense que personne n'y
croit et pas même lui donc reste
effectivement la seule solution qui est
la majorité texte par texte ce qui va
créer un certain nombre de problèmes on
entendait sur ce plateau tout à l'heure
les les députés du rassemblement
national étant accusé par la france a
soumises à deux finalement être
presque porter ne les en solaire de
texte pour certains texte d'emmanuel
macro ils sont visiblement dans une
opposition plus constructive donc
effectivement si les députés du front
national se mettent à voter sur certains
textes dans le même sens que la majorité
présidentielle
ça va être compliqué de toute façon on
savait de la godille donc ça va être
compliqué toute la question est de
savoir combien de temps tout cela
pourra-t-il durée mais on voit bien que
la stratégie d' emmanuel macron quand
même c'est de retourner de retourner la
difficulté aux groupes politiques et dit
moi j'agis pour les français les
français ont voulu ça au mois d'avril me
réélire ils ont voulu ça au mois de juin
faire cette assemblée très diverses
maintenant vous vous avez une
responsabilité aussi sur vous voulez
améliorer le quotidien des français soit
vous ne voulez rien faire et on sent que
cet argument va être utilisé très fort
notamment contre la france a soumises
pour dire ah le pouvoir d'achat tout ça
c'est pas suffisant pour vous donc vous
ne voulez rien faire voilà un peu le
genre d'ambiance dans laquelle quand
même tout ça va se dérouler négocier des
compromis texte par tex ce n'est pas la
culture l'agent faut des des français
c'est presque pire d'ailleurs qu'une
cohabitation marie roger biloa commencé
vu de l'étranger et du cameroun en
particulier où vous vous trouvez
on l'a déjà pu percevoir du poker
européen
c'est alors une réaction ambivalente on
a vu
certains gens placent s'inquiéter du
fait que
la france a soumises un sport important
qu elle s
macro on va pouvoir
continuer à mener son agenda européen et
même vis-à-vis de cette guerre
et en même temps du côté allemand on
avoir chacun se réjouir de ce que la
france arrive
peut-être par une fraction a eu une
nécessaire politique qui inclut qui
donne un peu plus de poids à au
parlement est ici jusqu'au il ya de
l'intérêt cet intérêt même si celle de
la classe politique y aller dès parce
que c'est assez inédit et que les
systèmes politiques des pays
francophones
son gérant calqués sur ceux de la france
et et ça veut dire que dans la plupart
d'oublier le parlement ne joue pas un
grand rôle
voilà il est une espèce de fès
d'enregistrement dans le meilleur des
cas et donc là il ya un intérêt à voir
comment emmanuel macron va pouvoir gérer
cette assemblée disparates lui même il a
parlé non pas de pluralisme ça me
frapper
quelques valeurs mais deux divisions
voilà c'est ce parlement reflet de la
division du pays d'auray plus dire le
pluralisme donc on voit aussi que
il aura beaucoup de mal avec ça et ça ça
va être observée parce que justement on
a on a toute une série de sujets sur
lesquels on aurait aimé que le parlement
soit comme ce concert soit consulté
notamment la politique d habiter pays
africains qui a été toujours
dirigé est décidé à l'elysée des fois
par des petits jeunes dans un bureau et
c'est donc ça
merci beaucoup marie roger biloa pour ce
regard du cameroun où nous rejoignent et
évidemment très bientôt ici sur ce
plateau merci à vous mary deros et est
on va plus loin et nous on se retrouve
dans moins de trois minutes pour un
nouveau journal dans paris dec
[Musique]
austérité